Speaker 1: Let's go next to Kevin from I hope
I pronounce this correctly.
Is it took Willa?
Speaker 3: It's so cool to quill your.
Speaker 1: Okay.
What state is that in?
Speaker 3: It is in Washington state.
It's like ten miles south from Seattle.
Speaker 1: All right.
Well, welcome to the show.
What's on your mind today?
Speaker 3: Well, it's been a while since we
last talked.
And I will go to you for some really important
questions, and we don't know the answer to
them.
And then I have one in particular.
I have a follow up.
Speaker 1: Okay.
Speaker 3: So the question I have is, do you
feel that the Biden's green energy plan through
the Inflation Reduction Act is is like selling
the cart before the horse?
Speaker 1: In what sense?
Speaker 3: Like, for instance, for instance
there is nersa and they're concerned that
the that these green energy projects might
not there is a problem through there's a process
that makes it so these green energy projects
are not in and giving and given the permitting.
At the other piece they should be getting
in their current the current system.
And that's why that's why Senator Manchin
introduced permitting reform.
And there's also the concern that perhaps
like.
There's an there's a there's a button, but
there's probably not enough people that can
assume that can take on the initial jobs.
No screen.
Speaker 1: Oh, I see what you're saying.
No, listen, I'm not concerned by that because
sometimes in order to create.
So you've got to generate.
If if the government doesn't first fund some
of these things, the businesses aren't going
to start hiring and training the people to
do the work because in general, businesses
aren't going to say, Hey, the government might
pass this, so let's like hire and train a
whole bunch of people.
So I don't see that as a bottleneck.
I don't see it as a problem.
It might serve as a temporary bottleneck,
but I think the right way to do it is the
government says, Hey, we're investing in these
industries, go grow, hire, train people and
there will be a lag time.
But that's okay.
Speaker 3: I see.
But do you do you also feel that there might
be some you know, some.
Some some additional ways to make the process
a little bit more and more more efficient.
Assuming there's a dire need to meet the demand
for addressing climate change.
Speaker 1: I'm sure there are.
And whether it's government assisting in the
training so that people can be hired more
quickly to do some of the jobs for these energy
retrofits to move to new renewable technologies.
Or I'm sure there's a dozen ways to do it.
But bottom line, I think the right way is
the government says we're investing in this
stuff.
We're going to get right to it and then figure
out figure out the rest.
All right, Kevin, thank you very much for
the call.
I do appreciate it.
Let's go next to Mike from Massachusetts.
Mike from Massachusetts, welcome to the program.
What's on your mind today?
Speaker 2: Hey, David.
Thanks for having me.
Pleasure.
You hear me All right?
Yeah, I can hear you fine.
Awesome.
So my so obviously, with everything going
on in the country lately, like, you know,
especially especially on, like, you know,
the front of, like, the LGBTQ rights.
Well, know, Tennessee just banned gender affirming
care, I think, for minors.
I think Mississippi did recently too, or something
like that.
But there's a lot and plenty of other topics
as well.
Things just don't look awesome at the moment.
So it's you know, I was looking into kind
of how in the 2020 election and the 2022 election,
it seems that younger voters, particularly
Gen Z, as they're becoming a voting age now,
seem to be changing the electorate.
The face of the electorate.
And I came across this sort of report or maybe
more of a study from the Brookings Institute
that they updated in 2020, that kind of project,
how, you know, project how, you know, baby
boomers getting older and Gen Z getting older,
and just where the Republican and Democratic
Party stand on certain social issues.
Yeah, how they project that the electorate
is going to change and how various states
are going to change political leaning wise
right over the next decade or so.
And I know maybe this is a little naive to
say, but even the most conservative friendly
model from that report is exceptionally optimistic,
looking for the Democrats.
So it's kind of a two part question.
One, do you believe that all these demographic
shifts and the potentially continued demographic
shifts that a lot of people seem to be portraying
coming down the line with Gen Z and the diversification
of voters?
Yeah.
Do you think those are genuine reasons to
be optimistic going forward for the next decade
or so?
Speaker 1: You know, I do think so.
But at the same time, it's been 12 years at
least, of people saying the demographic shifts
in Texas are going to make it a red state,
a blue state.
The demographic shifts in Georgia are going
to make it a blue state.
And it's like, well, Georgia did vote for
some Democratic senators.
That's true.
But continued Republican governors in Texas,
I mean, yes, the 2020 presidential was as
close as it has been in decades, but it's
definitely not a blue state.
So on the one hand, the the predictions and
the models seem sound.
But I'm also aware that people have been talking
about this for 12 years and it hasn't yet
happened.
So so I think it's plausible that it will
eventually happen, but I don't think it it's
a strategy for Democrats anytime soon to just
rely on demographic changes.
Speaker 2: No, I understand.
And I think like, yes, people have definitely
been talking about certain states, particularly
Texas, shifting from red to blue.
Yeah, for quite a while now.
It seems like we are kind of finally reaching
a point.
I guess I would use the term inflection point.
Yeah.
Where, you know, the oldest baby boomers and
I don't mean to be morbid about this, but
the oldest baby boomers are only a year or
two away from the average life expectancy
in this country.
So that voting base is going to start declining
in Gen Z, which is by every poll we can find
overwhelmingly liberal and progressive.
Speaker 1: No, I agree.
I agree.
It's a it's just a matter of when.
And so in the meantime, we've got to do the
best we can to win elections the normal ways,
which is making the right case on issues,
doing the campaigning, doing the work, etc..
But at some point I see it as hopefully a
bonus that is coming, which is the demographic
advantages.
Speaker 2: Oh, absolutely.
They definitely have to keep campaigning to
win people over.
They can't just rely on these changes, but
it will make things easier.
And I guess the second part of my question
is if these projections end up being even
relatively accurate, I mean.
What exactly would be a possible approach
for the Republican Party to remain politically
relevant.
They're already.
Speaker 1: Doing it.
It's just trying to steal the.
I mean, that's why they're already doing it.
They're already losing on policy with the
electorate that we have.
And so the approach is let's make it harder
for people to vote.
Let's say we won even when we didn't win.
Let's look at purging voter rolls.
They're doing all that stuff.
They're just going to do even more of it.
Speaker 2: No, 100%.
It's just I feel like this can only get you
so far.
Well, we'll.
Speaker 1: See.
I mean, let's let.
Let's see.
Let's see how far it gets them in 24 and then
go from there.
Speaker 2: Fair enough.
Fair enough.
Like I said, it was just something that I
came across and I was like, Is this too good
to be true or is this genuine reason for optimism
in the next decade or so?
So, you know, I mean, let's just hope that
the ship, the ships keep happening and the
Democrats keep not completely shooting themselves
in the foot.
Speaker 1: All right.
Mike from Massachusetts, very much well-said.
Always good to hear
from you.